Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Marvel video Marvel
just made a bunch of big announcements
about butch going on with our Marvel
phase 4 schedule the movies because of
the virus during 2020 things are being
canceled things are being delayed so
we'll break everything down because of
what's going on we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about Marvel phase 4 on the
video I'll just break this down top 5
style starting with number 5 so
recently a lot of Studios have started
canceling their movie releases during
March and April r.i.p new mutants for
the 4th time press F in the chat for
that movie but then what changed just a
couple days ago in the United States at
least at a few other major countries is
that virtually all movie theater chains
were ordered to shut down for a much
longer period of time between eight
weeks in a couple months it's different
for each major theater chain but it
almost makes it impossible to actually
physically go out and see a movie for a
couple months so after that escalated
Marvel preemptively canceled the Black
Widow movie premiere like we all kind of
thought that they might that was
originally happening at the beginning of
May it seemed like it might be safe
since it was so far out but the theater
shut down will extend beyond that so
there's no point in them trying to
release Black Widow until all the
theaters are back to normal later this
year at least in the United States so
number 4 when Marvel took Black
Widow off the schedule it did not give
it a new release date so it's literally
just sitting on a shelf on a giant hard
drive somewhere in Kevin Feige office
right now best case scenario is Marvel
releases it between the end of May just
pushes it a couple weeks and early July
originally Marvel was going to release
guardians of the galaxy 3 July 31st of
this year when they postponed that they
didn't replace it with anything there's
no Disney movie that's now coming out at
the end of July so wouldn't be weird for
them to just push Black Widow to July if
they wanted to
and as for guardians of the galaxy 3
right now it looks like it's coming out
sometime during 2022 based on James
Gunn's production schedule he said that
he's going to finish doing the Suicide
Squad reboot movie then he's going to start
working on guardians 3 Vin Diesel was
even nice enough to drop that the
Guardians will definitely crossover with
Thor for love and thunder and Thor will
also show up during guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 even though anybody who saw
the end of Avengers endgame just kind of
expected that they would somehow follow
up on this moment of Thor with the
guardians as guardians of the galaxy
together again we just didn't know quite
how that was going to play out and what
it would look like now it sounds like
the guardians will just cameo during
Thor 4 in Thor will just cameo during
guardians 3 but they're not going to call
Guardians 3 as guardians of the galaxy
number 3 when they made the Black
Widow announcement Marvel also answered
a bunch of questions about the rest of
the Marvel phase 4 timeline on all the
other movies the Disney Plus series
because there's a lot of stuff coming
out later this year everyone wondering
if they postponed Black Widow is that
going to mess up the flow of all the Marvel
phase 4 storytelling and everything
that's coming the next couple of years
all the Disney Plus series all the
Marvel movies are supposed to be
connected so there's a logic to when
they're releasing things and why they're
coming in a certain order the reason why
Black Widow is coming now right after
avengers endgame is because we literally
just saw her die during avengers endgame
so one you kind of want to get that
story out before you wait too long
they're trying to explain why she
sacrificed herself over Hawkeye on
Vermeer and pushed the Marvel phase four
story forward by teasing upcoming
Thunderbolt Ross super soldier weapons
Plus program in the thunderbolts yes it
would have made more sense to release
her movie during Marvel phase 3 or even
back during Marvel phase 2 I'm sure a
lot of people's reviews when the movie
actually does come out will reference
that fact like this feels like a Marvel
phase 3 movie even though they're trying
to release it during Marvel phase 4 so I
do think a lot of the stuff that they
added to the Black Widow movie that
connects it to stuff that happens after
Avengers endgame after her death is just
in service of trying to make that more
relevant to Marvel phase 4 because the
movie takes place between Captain
America Civil War in Avengers infinity
war so I think a lot of the marketing is
actually just dealing with the confusion
that people are having over where this
movie fits in what's going on with Black
Widow during it thankfully Marvel just
came out and said that any black widow
delays won't affect the rest of the
Marvel phase 4 release schedule in
storytelling so number 2 what's
going on with Disney's plans to release
stuff on Disney Plus in VOD instead of
in theaters all the major studios have
started doing this with some of their
movies that are coming out right now
like Vin Diesel's bloodshot another
Marvel actor doing another movie at Sony
it just hit theaters a week ago but Sony
is releasing it on VOD next week
Universal did the same thing with some
of their big movies that are coming out
right now but here's the thing
none of the studios have done this yet
with a major major tentpole movie Fast
and Furious 9 also Vin Diesel movie is a
good example
Universal just push that a full year to
April of next year instead of trying to
release it on VOD with the other
Universal movies that it's releasing
right now on VOD so everyone's really
just doing it with the smaller budget
movies and the movies that it didn't
think we're going to earn a lot of money
at the box office so right now it is
very possible that Marvel could release
New Mutants on VOD the budget for that
was way under a hundred million dollars
it's easier for Marvel to earn most of
the money back on that because
technically they're saddled with all
those Fox films when Disney bought Fox
the reason why they probably won't
release Black Widow early on VOD or on
Disney Plus is because the budget was
way over a hundred and fifty million
dollars probably closer to 175 million
and that doesn't include the marketing
costs the real reason why Studios don't
want to release their giant tentpole
films on VOD right now is because movies
typically have six different times that
they earn money in the lifecycle of the
movie there's the theatrical release
which for Black Widow could earn between
700 million and a billion dollars then
they release it on VOD and Home Video
another round of profits other giant
pile of cash then they license the movie
to cable channels like HBO they make
another dump truck of cash then they
release the movie on streaming platforms
like Netflix obviously Disney Plus and
earn even more money yet again if they
skip all those steps and go straight to
streaming they miss out on almost a
billion dollars of profit on the Black
Widow movie the reason why they might be
okayed doing that with New Mutants is
just because there's no way that movie
was ever going to earn a billion dollars
at the box office so number one this
is what's happening with the rest of the
Marvel phase 4 schedule right now even
though everything is kind of on a break
too
for the next couple of weeks bare
minimum could be longer than that but
there is not a hiatus Marvel said Falcon
and Winter Soldier is still going to
premiere in August and continue the
weapons Plus program super soldier
Thunderbolts story then Marvel said it's
still releasing the Eternals movie in
November that explains the ancient
origins of the MCU helps set up
modern day mutants and x-men characters
I'll do separate videos about the
Eternals we're supposed to get a trailer
for that in May but because of the
delays they might push that just a
little bit in December they released the
wandavision episodes also explaining
scarlet witch's reality warping chaos
magic powers the multiverse and teasing
more mutants in the MCU through her twin
children with vision Marvel's shang-chi
movie did go on break for a couple weeks
but it's still being released in
February 2021 Marvel hasn't said a lot
about how that deepens the Avengers
level storytelling but they're playing a
lot on the Iron Man Easter eggs from the
ten rings in Iron Man 3 in the Mandarin
hopefully they'll bring Trevor back for
a cameo somehow they're billing the
movie kind of like Bruce Lee's Enter the
Dragon if it were made inside the MCU
with Marvel characters the Loki series
is still supposed to come out around
late March sometime next year it's only
six episodes it'll introduce more
multiverse level villains then right
after that is Doctor Strange two
multiverse of madness which was full
blown multiverse teasing alternate
versions of MCU characters from other
realities fun fact to Kevin Smith also
said on his podcast recently that Markus
and McFeely the writers of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame
literally showed him footage on their
phones of the Avengers Infinity Ward
deleted scene of Doctor Strange becoming
the iron mage with Benedict Cumberbatch
literally wearing a real physical Iron
Man suit that they built for him for the
movie that looked just like this I did a
whole video about that deleted scene a
couple weeks ago so we'll add a link to
it at the end of this hopefully they'll
bring that deleted scene back around and
incorporated into Doctor Strange too
somehow
spider-man 3 is supposed to come out
July 2021 Tom Holland said that they're
still starting to film that in July of
this year then they do Thor for love and
thunder November 2021 in Hawkeye is
supposed to come out sometime around
then either before or after Thor 4 they
haven't said which so if you have any
big questions about
what's going on right now with all the
Marvel movies in the Disney Plus series
just write them below in the comments
and I'll just try to keep up with
everything as Marvel continues to make
big announcements about what's going on
I'm working on a new Fantastic Four
video so that should post sometime
tomorrow as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that when I post it
congratulations Scary Berry you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for that Avengers
infinity saga deleted scene of Ironman
becoming Doctor Strange and Doctor
Strange becoming the iron mage and click
here for my new spider-man 3 marvel
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!